India is one of the most exhilarating travel destinations on Earth.
India is a great destination for backpackers and tourists...
...looking for one of the cheapest places to visit.
You can get by on closer to 30 dollars by staying in cheap guesthouses,...
...taking second class trains and avoiding Western food.
India is a cheap backpacking destination.
With a rich cultural history, top of class food...
...helpful and curious locals, incredible regional diversity,...
...great tea and a lot to do,...
...India is perfect for backpackers because you can experience all of this...
...by spending very little money each day.
You can book a mid-range hotel room for 30 to 40 dollars...
...or a hostel for as little as 15 dollars a night.